The joe rogan experience.
Everybody like as far as I'm concerned,
like mom,
I got my daily problems.
I,
I don't,
I don't the government and
the clamp down the internet,
fuck the Internet.
I honestly told her,
I've said many,
many times if I could
get rid of one thing,
like I think for every great thing the
Internet's done and there's a thousand
slimy,
he's coming fucking awful
rotten things about it.
Wow.
That's interesting.
I look at it a completely
opposite I think for everyone.
I mean it changed my,
it changed the trajectory of a
whole business depended on to,
you know what man?
I think Dan took the carpet enabled on
delivery on levels that I never would
have imagined in like 1995 it thievery
meaning people to illegally downloaded
songs.
Yeah.
Not only that.
Okay.
And then let's just go with the,
you know,
just small things like,
back,
you know,
maybe in the 90s if there was
a guy who liked fucking pigs,
you know what I mean?
He'd be alone fucking wolf somewhere that,
you know,
would never really act on it or anything.
Now there's probably,
you could probably find a
website dedicated to that gap.
This most certainly if people
gather and they fuck pigs,
that's bad.
That's bad for society.
Yeah.
Why is it okay to eat pigs?
But it's not okay to fuck them.
That's what I want to know.
I mean,
I feel like you dude podcast
might be over after that.
I don't feel like,
I don't know if I have any
response to that legitimately.
I don't feel like that makes any sense.
I feel like,
uh,
if you,
you know,
if you will fuck people and we
didn't eat and them's wrong,
uh,
well site and wrong.
If you trapped car crashed in the Andes
mountains and just eating a person,
well people have done it.
I mean,
the whole bond or party,
those people that got
stuck in the Rockies,
people done it.
But it's under notoriously bad story.
Like it's not cool.
They're accepted.
It's not like things you
should do on a regular basis.
But I mean,
if someone can,
pigs,
let's just apply the same,
probably the same logic.
How about you're stuck on an island
and there's no people to fuck,
but you got a pig and they come
back after all these years and the,
hey man,
what are you doing?
Like,
well,
I raised pigs and a and
I killed them for food.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
What would you do for sex?
He just beat off lot.
Nah,
fuck my pigs.
They'd be like,
whoa and cool.
Not Cool.
He did something.
She just kept that to yourself,
man.
You know?
That's really what it is.
Would it be worse if he
made love to the pig?
I don't think either one is bad.
I think honestly,
if you're going to kill an animal,
fucking it,
as long as you don't
like fuck it to death.
That's kind of a crazy way
to kill something and we'd
just go anal with the pig
or vagina.
She'd have to see the setup.
You have to see what you deal with,
you know,
condom,
no condom.
It's about a question.
Internal organ lies.
Pigs are supposed to
be very similar to us,
so you don't,
you definitely don't want to go
aina without a little cleanup.
First.
I mean,
you get some pig shit through
the tip of your Dick for sure.
That can be a problem at home clubs.
Nice.
It's nice to have a spot.
So like we're standing.
Hope is out in Bisbee.
There's no fucking club.
So that crazy asshole.
Just do a show in his back yard.
Set up some speakers,
plugged the Mike and
he did a show in Vegas
and some dude's backyard.
There was a guy in Vegas,
some kid who was hiring comedians do shows
in his yard and have his friends come
over and uh,
has to be a great gig.
No.
Can you say about it right?
Standup said it was awesome.
Like we got it.
Got It got shut down by like
city ordinances or something.
Yeah.
He didn't have the proper permits.
Let a bummer.
What the fuck is that one
with the proper [inaudible].
Well then you could shut
down lemonade stands.
You know,
so you don't,
and you don't have a permit.
Right.
But you don't want anybody throwing
like crazy late night parties in the
backyard next to you.
That would suck.
Like,
what if they were playing bad rap music?
Like you're cool with it if it's stand up.
And it's funny,
like at Stan hope do her standing up tall,
terrible,
whoo,
whoo.
And you'd try to get some
fucking sleep and you're like,
God damn it,
this is def.
Maybe that's how they
feel about Stan hope.
Talking about aids.
When I,
uh,
when I turned 16,
my parents made the tactical error of
going out of town that weekend and I threw
one of the biggest parties
Oviedo high school had ever seen.
And there were cars parked all down the
block and just massive party and people
just,
you know,
drinking on,
I,
I was,
uh,
talking to like three of the
hottest girls in my school,
in our living room,
and this guy vomits on the,
on our living room,
carpet.
You know what I mean?
What am I do?
I'm gonna get down on my hands and knees,
you know,
in the middle of this party or the,
the,
these girls that I,
I care about,
uh,
you know,
watch me cleaned some vomit.
So what'd you do?
Sprinkled some dog food on
it and let the dog in now.
No.
Did you really?
Oh,
you fucking Sao human being.
Why would you want to dog
me drinking this cost?
It was a the cleanest carpet area
that dog haunted you wake dog farts.
Poor dog.
Come on.
Rip and horrible farts.
Bio farts.
Worst me here.
Your dog's Fart.
When you look over at him and be like,
come on man.
For Real.
Hey,
that's when the dog is
comfortable with you.
They're always comfortable with your man.
They never hold in farts.
I was just something about dogs.
They never figured it out.
You yell at them when they farm.
They never put two and two together
like what the fuck you yelling at,
man,
I'm just over here doing my thing.
I'm just being me.
I didn't even move fucking stinky bitch.
I don't want to be an ass.
I wanna.
I wanna make sure that people understand
that I think is that people are working
at the limits of their understanding.
We have burnt athletes at the,
at the stake of performance that we
didn't understand all the ramifications of
got the job done.
We lived on the clock.
Let me use an analogy for you.
I learned this from you.
This is like,
this is one of the from me.
Yes.
This is one of the swear to
God guiding forces in my life.
Don't hang tough.
Okay.
Fear factor.
Oh,
this guy had eat like a foot
long horse cock in like an hour.
Okay.
That never happened.
But go ahead.
Uh,
there was a hang tough.
He had eats something.
So you guys eating right and he's
making jokes and you're like,
hey bro,
watch the clock.
It was like in the best
of fear factor too,
right?
Like watch the clock,
watch the clock.
You're trying to help them,
your coach and he's making jokes.
He's flirting with the girls.
He's eating any swallows.
The last bite at the last second and a,
you're like,
sorry bro,
you timed out and the guy freaks out.
Yeah,
I remember that dude.
I was trying to tell that guy,
I know what you're doing,
but you can't do it.
Don't do it.
Don't fucking waste your
energy talking and having fun.
I'm like,
you've got a lot.
I,
I've been there before.
I've seen a lot of people eat dick.
It takes some time,
takes some serious fucking time.
And you think you take the first
couple of bites like I'm fine.
Did you do you got five minutes?
Eat that whole deck.
It's not that easy in
cobble and Dick got that.
He got to watch the clock.
You gotta manage the details.
You also have to have chewing
endurance and that sounds so crazy,
but there's shit like livers and kidneys.
Kidneys is a perfect one.
Somebody tells you,
Hey,
I'm going to make a bet with you.
Listen,
you wanna make some money.
Tell him mother fucker he can't
eat a kidney like a cow kidney.
Tell him that he can't eat it in an hour
cause he's not going to fucking eat it
just to make sure he can't have any water.
You can't wash it down with shit.
You just have to eat it.
It's not happening.
Okay?
It's not going to happen.
It shouldn't happen.
You know how I know I'm an expert on that.
I know.
I've seen,
I've seen a lot of people.
I've Seen Pa's do it for 100 bucks.
I've seen contestants do what?
You can't eat it.
It's too hard.
It's,
you'd shooting the shit out of something.
It's like you're running up
hill sprints with your jaw.
That's what it's like.
That's right.
You're wrestling Karalyn with your jaw.
Can't train for that.
The kidney is insurmountable that you
have to control what you can control.
Right?
So,
so you learn that from me.
I've got to control the clock,
Bro.